L
THE KINDNESS YOU SPREAD KEEP
COMING BACK TO YOU.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, MSNBC.
SOME SAY KAMALA HARRIS,
KAMALA HARRIS, WHATEVER WE'RE
GOING WITH THIS KIND OF FUNNY
BECAUSE SHE CAN'T EVEN PRONOUNCE
HER OWN FIRST NAME, IT CHANGES.
BUT SHE'D LIKE YOU TO KNOW THAT
DESPITE APPEARANCES, SHE DOES
HAVE SOME PRETTY DEEP
PRINCIPLES.
>> WE ARE UNITED BY THE
FUNDAMENTAL BELIEF THAT EVERY
HUMAN BEING IS OF INFINITE
WORTH, DESERVING OF COMPASSION,
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
>> Tucker: BUT THERE WAS A
CAVEAT, UNSTATED AT THE TIME,
THAT EVERYONE DESERVES DIGNITY
AND RESPECT EXCEPT THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK FOR KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY DON'T GET IT, AND NOW THEY
ARE GOING ON THE RECORD TO
EXPLAIN.
ONE STAFFER IN HER OFFICE "HAD A
SENSE OF PARANOIA THAT YOU NEVER
KNEW WHEN SHE WAS GOING TO SNAP
AT YOU."
SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT?
AND OTHERS THAT EMPLOYEES WERE
"SO STRESSED OUT THEY WERE
MAKING THEMSELVES SICK."
SO KAMALA HARRIS, CHAMPION OF
WOMEN, ACTUALLY WAS MARINATING
IN A TOXICS TO OF TOXIC
MASCULINITY.
JESSE KELLY IS STIFFEST AGAIN IT
ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND
THIS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON, ARE YOU
SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT
KAMALA HARRIS, IF THAT IS WHAT
SHE'S GOING BY, IS LIKE THE
WORST BOSS IN WASHINGTON AND
NASTY TO THE PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
HER?
>> IT'S THE MOST PREDICABLE
THING IN THE WORLD.
EVERYONE WATCHING YOU RIGHT NOW
HAS WORKED FOR OR WORKED WITH
SOMEBODY WHO JUST HAS AMBITION
JUST DRIPPING OFF OF THEIR PORES
AND THAT IS KAMALA HARRIS.
THOSE TYPES OF PEOPLE WILL DO
ANYTHING TO GET AHEAD, THEY
TREAT THEIR BOSSES LIKE A CRAP,
THEY TREAT THEIR EMPLOYEES LIKE
CRAP.
THAT IS WHY SHE KNIFED JOE BIDEN
IN THE DEBATE WITH ALL THE RACE
NONSENSE, THERE WAS NO REASON TO
DO THAT.
IT IS WHAT SHE CACKLED LIKE A
HYENA ANYTIME SHE IS ASKED IN A
COMFORTABLE QUESTION.
IT'S THE SAME REASON SHE STARTED
HER POLITICAL YEAR AS A
BRATWURST BUN.
KAMALA HARRIS WILL DO ANYTHING
TO GET AHEAD.
>> Tucker: OF GOD TO SAY WHEN
I LOOK AT
HER YOU CAN FEEL THE FEAR AND
FALSE PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS AFRAID
BECAUSE THEY ARE TERRIFIED YOU T
WHO THEY REALLY ARE.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW HOW TO
PRONOUNCE THEIR FIRST NAMES OR
PEOPLE WHO GREW UP IN CANADA AND
PRETEND THEY DIDN'T.
SHE SEEMS TERRIFIED ALWAYS OF
BEING EXPOSED.
>> SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE IN
ANYTHING AND PEOPLE WITHOUT ANY
GROUNDING, THEY ARE REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING CALLED OUT
ON IT.
KAMALA HARRIS IS ALWAYS PAINTED
US THIS FAR LEFT WING OR, IF SHE
THOUGHT HER POLITICAL AMBITIONS
WOULD DO BETTER ON THE RIGHT,
KAMALA HARRIS WOULD BE TO THE
RIGHT OF MARIGOLD WHILE THERE
TOMORROW.
SHE BELIEVES ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
EXCEPT KAMALA HARRIS.
THAT IS ALL SHE'S EVER BEEN.
SHE DOESN'T LOOK AT THEM AS
PEOPLE LIKE A SECRETARY OR AN
ASSISTANT, THEY ARE ALL JUST
STEPPING-STONES SHE CAN STOMP ON
ON HER WAY TO THE TOP JOB.
AS SOON AS THEY THROW POOR JOE
OUT THE BACK DOOR AND
KAMALA HARRIS IS IN THE FRONT
OFFICE SHE WILL MOVE ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SUCH A GOOD
POINT, IT WOULD BE FUNNY TO
BRIBE HER POLLSTER THAT -- AN
ATTACK ON CIRCUMCISION OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND WATCH
HER GIVE AN IMPASSIONED SPEECH.
SHE WOULD.
>> SHE WAS THROWING PEOPLE IN
PRISON ALL DAY LONG IN
CALIFORNIA AS THIS ABSOLUTE
BALL-BUSTING, THROWING PEOPLE IN
JAIL FOR ANYTHING SHE COULD
POSSIBLY THINK OF AND NOW SHE
GOES TO THE SENATE, SHE'S THE
MOST LEFT-WING SENATOR.
THIS WOMAN DOESN'T BELIEVE IN
ANYTHING EXCEPT FOR ACHIEVING
THE NEXT THING.
LIKE I SAID, EVERYBODY WATCHING
IS ALREADY THINKING OF SOMEBODY.
THEY KNOW SOMEONE IN THEIR LIFE
LIKE THAT.
THEY ARE ALWAYS TERRIBLE PEOPLE,
UNIVERSALLY.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.